من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في ديير البلح
ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت هشام
في هذا اليوم الجديد من الغارات
الاسرائيليه المكثفه التي شملت مناطق
عديده من القطاع اطلعنا على اخر التطورات
لديك بالفعل الغارات الاسرائيليه شملت
كافه محفظات قطاع غزه ومنطقه الوسط وسط
القطاع كان لها نصيب كبير من هذه الغارات
الاسرائ
الغارات ما بين الفينه والاخرى تتجدد سواء
الجويه منها او حتى المدفعيه التي تقصف
بعنف المناطق الشرقيه لمنطقه دير البلح
كما هو الحال في منطقه شرق خان يونس كما
هو الحال في المحافظات في مدينه غزه
المحاف المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه غزه لا سما
حي الشجاعيه كما هو الحال ايضا في جباليه
شمال القطاع وبالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي
متواصل من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ربما
ينخفض شيئا فشيئا مع ساعات الصب لا سما
الغارات الجويه لكنه يتكثف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه كانت هناك عده غارات نفذتها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه على دير
البلح وسط القطاع وعلى مخيم النصيرات وعلى
مخيم البريج واستهدفت في جلها منازل مدنيه
فلسطينيه قصفتها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه ودمرتها وسوتها بالارض على
رؤوس السكان ونحن نتحدث عن وسط قطاع غزه
هذا هذه المناطق هي مناطق طلب الجيش
الاسرائيلي من سكان مدينه غزه وشمال
القطاع التوجه اليها
الان نسبه واعداد النازحين فيها هي اعداد
كبيره وبالتالي اي قصف لمنزل في تلك
المناطق هو بكل تاكيد يحتوي على نازحين
فلسطينيين هربوا من القصف الاسرائيلي في
مناطق مختلفه وبالتالي يقتلوا في هذه
المناطق التي اعتقدوا انها امنه بالتالي
هناك اعداد من عشرات من الشهداء والاصابات
وصلت الى هنا الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
ويجري الان التحضير لعمليه تشييع هذه
الجثامين او بعض من هذه الجثامين الى
المقابر لكن حتى الوصول الى المقبره هو
مهمه صعبه في وسط قطاع غزه الحصول على قبر
هو مهمه شبه مستحيله هنا في وسط القطاع لا
سما في ظل الاعداد الكبيره للشهداء
والجارى منذ بدايه الحرب الاسرائيليه
سيقوم بصلاه الجنازه هنا ولكن ستبقى
الجثامين على الارض ربما لعده ساعات حتى
يبحث اقارب هؤلاء الشهداء وجيرانهم عن قبر
لهم في احد المقابر في احدى المقابر في
وسط قطاع غزه وربما لا يجد ويضطر لابقائها
هنا حتى يوم اخر من اجل مزيد من البحث عن
مقبره يمكن ان تتسع لهذه الجثامين جميع من
يدفن في المناطق الوسطى هم يدفنون في
مقابر جماعيه ولا يوجد قبر لشهيد واحد على
الاقل كما كان يحدث في الماضي الان
المقابر هي مقابر جماعيه وبالكاد يستطيعون
الحصول على هذا القبر الجماعي الصغير الذي
يمكن ان يكفي ل عش جثامين مع بعضها البعض
وبالتالي ايضا الوصول الى المقبره هي مهمه
صعبه كانت في الماضي سيارات الاسعاف هي من
تقل هذه الجثامين الى المقبره الان لا
يوجد سيارات اسعاف ب تعمل وتستطيع الوصول
الى هذه المقابر لاسما في ظل النقص الحاد
في الوقود في الذي ايضا هو يصل الى
هذه اسعافات وبالتالي كل عمليات الدفن
والحصول على قبر هي عمليات صعبه لا سما في
ظل هذه الاوضاع وبكل تاكيد المستشفيات
ايضا تعاني من جراء هذه الاوضاع الصعبه هي
تعاني من نقص في الادويه تعاني من نقص في
الوقود تعاني من نقص في المياه وفي كل شيء
النقص هو سمه هذه الايام لا سما في ظل منع
اسرائيل وصول الوقود الى هذه المستشفيات
هذه المستشفيات باتت مكتظه الناس هنا
الذين نزحوا تضاعفت الاعداد بشكل كبير
وبالتالي يحتاجوا الى دواء والى علاج حتى
الامراض المزمنه تحتاج الى دواء وعلاج
بشكل يومي ولكن كل هذا غير متوفر ناهيك عن
الاوضاع المعيشيه الصعبه التي يعيشها
النازحون هنا في قطاع غزه وفي وسط القطاع
وفي جنوبه خاصه في ظل النقص في الدواء
والنقص في وصول المساعدات والنقص في
الغذاء والنقص ايضا في المياه الصالحه
للشرب وبالتالي الامراض تزداد والضغط على
هذه المستشفيات يزداد بالاضافه الى الجرحى
والمصابين والشهداء الذين يصلون من جراء
القصف الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هي عمليه معقده
ومركبه واوضاع ماساويه كارثيه يعيشها سكان
قطاع غزه وتنعكس وتنعكس بشكل سلبي على هذه
المستشفيات شكرا جزيلا لك هشام زقوت
مراسلنا من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح